[Music]
have you guys heard of the term
flavortown yeah have you heard of it
won't you take me to his name my fairy
hair Oh
so this dude he always says flavortown
or something it's good person he's a
good person why now you know you met him
he does a lot of charities he does he
actually is a firefighter charity
charity like during this whole pandemic
he has helped raise more than 20 million
dollars for restaurant workers huh what
about you Joe what have you done ceated
more than mapping he also has officiated
more than 100 lgbtq+ wedding oh that's
cool is he gay I don't know I don't
think so I'm not sure god I would love
for him to officiate the wedding just
wearing that's what he always wears yeah
yeah I love that he looks like he's
always going bowling he's a part of a
[ __ ] in 2001 rock band
yeah the shells all the time on his arm
Eddie has a shark hook [ __ ] necklace
so recently this man he started a
petition to change the name of Columbus
Ohio to flavortown so okay the guy dude
okay Eddie yeah I don't fear II so that
guy that's his hometown and his first
name is GUI actually Louie Fifi Eddie
you believe a dirty he's [ __ ] with you
yeah so Columbus you guys all know about
Christopher Columbus everybody hate him
right horrible he is [ __ ] that guy well
he was always a little misunderstood
really Stephen misunderstood how he
discovered the Americas and we ought to
thank him for that
he didn't even know what the Americas he
thought was something else
not sarcasm complete serious
but yeah so because of that a lot of
people oh well by the way the mayor of
Columbus has announced that they will
remove the statue of Christopher
Columbus that's outside City Hall and it
will be placed in storage and so for a
lot of people in the community they're
saying in this in this petition that a
lot of people in community that statue
represents patriarchy oppression and
divisive Ness because you want to I
think you could [ __ ] beam into
anything a human being has many
different spectrums or who they are and
it's easy to do that's understood I
think it's easy to judge based off of
our morals today I think they should put
a [ __ ] statue of the genie from
Aladdin the Robbie Williams genie okay I
think they should have Kim Jong good Oh
difference of opinion but actually were
you doing it is similar but not the
spirits they're totally good do we rub
it I want to rub it Kim Jong if I could
do me in that home : but it's also a
statue of arnold schwarzenegger there
are they gonna remove him Kyle really
because they have the Arnold the Arnold
the Arnold why did he choose such a [ __ ]
how to do that how because the venue's
are cheap didn't he didn't he didn't you
like famously harass women on assets and
stuff oh yeah he also [ __ ] his nanny
and had a kid with him yes we should
take a statue damn things at the
Columbus Ohio Convention Center if
there's a way but why is it a [ __ ] town
Joe it is there's nothing going on
[ __ ] boy
I never been there I'm not Masari
Colombians we've been there Ian's you
agree I'm just joking just replace all
the statues with dogs oh yeah okay so
here's the thing like I never liked
Columbus because I thought he was a
little [ __ ] I never liked his ass
you're more of a burden on kind of guy
huh man I'm more like a Captain Hook
kind of guy okay oh yeah he's same as
[ __ ] sick sick yeah but what we're
doing right now is I think it's a power
of who controls the story and narrative
of these figures
it's easy to judge a person's character
based off of what we know as today is
ethical or not so what we're trying to
do is we work we can't just delete
history altogether but I think it's not
about the leading history it's more
about like we're not gonna we're going
to honor this like we're not gonna put
it up and like well they should have be
gods right if someone accomplished
something right so for example let's say
someone accomplished something for
Humanity and he liked Pythagorean
theorem or whatever right like in
something that really or Tesla or
whatever like something amazing but we
find out that he likes to [ __ ] pigeons I
hope not but what if that that became
the case it's it's tough because like he
always liked pigeons yeah he look we
love pigeons and let's say he created
free energy everyone has their opinions
of pigeons right but does not saying
there's a disgrace understand right
does it discredit the fact that they did
something good something because humans
are not why we good and evil only humans
have many aspects of who they are right
like some of our founding members were
also slave owners and that [ __ ] sucks
because we know now that that's horrible
that's a horrible thing to do but back
then their time it was normalized even
though I think overall like in humanity
it's it's horrible to own another human
being in general it's [ __ ] up but it's
like can we blame them with the
standards we have today because if they
didn't make those mistakes we wouldn't
have learned that that was wrong for
humanity if we found a journal an old
journal for of neil armstrong's and it
had a bunch of [ __ ] up stuff in it
or do we go check take the the plaque
off the moon like that's the question
that joe is asked right thank you for
your contribution but you're not you
don't fit the mold today how about
statues are the contribution but not the
person just get rid of people I think we
should just replace them with chart let
all the statues with Charlie from all
those go to heaven or something I want
Fido
- we just need Clifford you know the doc
there you go he's red - that's a big
okay so here's the thing that I think
June I wonder what we should we should
show humans for what they are right so
like it's important to teach both facets
like so I don't know if I agree or
disagree yet about the throwing away the
statues changing names or not saying
that this person did this or whatever or
not recognizing someone for their work
right but I think it's important to say
hey this guy existed and this guy found
America for the European War museums are
for right but also guess what he was a
ship face like he went in and he
murdered these indigenous people and he
used them and he did but then when we're
children right like well the way we
learn things is like oh this guy was a
hero and I think that's what [ __ ] with
most people's minds is cuz you feel
deceived we're not getting the full
picture right and in so you you don't
realize the true story behind your kind
of brainwash that is a little kid that
that's right and then you see the
statues of them and it's just right and
you're like wait but that has nothing to
do with how I look how I got here
exactly so that's like for me the statue
stuff when I see that happening I'm like
it's cool to see change and I'm like for
those types of monuments I'm like look
we have places for them that they're
called museums let's leave them in there
and then we can go on and when the
history still save they're not honor but
at least the history is not erase and
it's it's where it needs to be yeah but
what if I like to go into the park could
eat a sandwich and look at a bunch of
colonialists who took over everything
like I I have that right I think as an
American I'm not even for this or
against it I'm just kind of doing I
think it's because I think in reality
right like what's happening is a
overcorrection because people who
weren't heard and pass are now heard
like the indigenous peoples of America
now they're heard because the the it was
a very Eurocentric perspective meaning
like hey Columbus did a good thing for
us Europeans they found this new world
let's represent that glory right but
then all these indigenous people are
like nah this guy [ __ ] suck he came
in and he killed all my ancestors and
then he brought it all these
new people that came in colonized the
land here so he's not a hero in my
America so now you see a difference in
perspective and now we're battling it
out to see which story wins and that's
just what I'm pointing it out yeah and
it's also like how much you want to zoom
in because you zoom in on anybody are
gonna find dirt right so even like
Martin Luther King he was a womanizer
he cheated on his wife and if you zoom
it on those things are we taking MLK day
away you know like there's some MLK in
every hood like s Street in every I
heard that Gandhi was a wife beater yeah
like so if you so if you start zooming
in everywhere it's like we are it's
gonna end up to a point I'm also with
Joe I don't agree or disagree with the
statute and the names or whatever it's
just that if we're gonna have this
conversation it needs to be a fair and
open conversation about everything and
it depends on how much we want to zoom
in and what is the context that we do
keep names or don't keep names yeah I
think at that point it would just be the
cleanest with something that's and dogs
just replace everything with something
that's not offensive I think that that's
really easy to do we should caches of
dicks and vaginas well we do that one
has it that could be offensive to some
people
bahah come on I never win circles and
everything circles are [ __ ] cool
triangle statue next to it okay anybody
own like triangle just Illuminati shapes
matter okay put them all on the same
statue okay no one seems sad you how's
that yeah I don't know it's so messy
because for me I'm like yeah it's a good
thing like [ __ ] yeah I like don't honor
a [ __ ] [ __ ] died in all this [ __ ]
to other human beings and like yeah it's
good that like racial representation
that was really harmful for certain
ethnicities is being removed yeah that's
awesome but yeah like where does it go
though like it does get a little like
message again goes back to like how much
one is doom in and also things are
subjective right so the most PC thing we
create right now let's say we do do a
dog on a triangle some way maybe in 2050
that is an offensive symbol now cuz
they're gonna be animal rights activist
that's like don't use these dogs we're
gonna take that
so which is it's a constant pattern of
erasing stuff it's just it just gets
really mess I got a racing but it's just
evolution you know what I mean like sign
of the times
yeah like his people just learn more
it's like the more you know the better
you should do yeah because I don't agree
with with the fact that we should just
like it's been there we should just be
like live with it mm-hmm I don't agree
with that either so yeah I don't know I
just think it's all a big distraction
because we're talking about the wrong
things I mean it's great it's great like
please represent your area change your
area do whatever you want people don't
have healthcare two million people like
losing their houses mortgage crisis like
we all talk about all this other [ __ ]
while the real [ __ ] I think goes down
and I wish that was on the news every
night
I wish to God so are they made me a
playwright I don't know I move there
so the petition has currently it has
ninety three thousand five hundred
ninety eight signatures we're trying to
get a hundred to a hundred and fifty
this is eight seven thousand more or no
how far did it be yeah that was it um
and also but like they tweeted this out
as soon as I heard they said Bud Light
Seltzer for all of flavortown if this
happens yeah there's gonna be trouble in
light self-service alright okay let me
kind of fine when they change the name
and then we tell people you live in
clear what's how nobody believes you
ever what was the one that you Gaines
there we go geez slow down in Florida
never robbed that plate isn't it um one
of the major cities in Florida it's not
a small town I think it is such a
meathead oh the only nose Gainesville
names
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]